estamos realizando transformaciones en
el plano ordenado y aquí dice realiza
una rotación de 180 grados alrededor del
punto cero aquí está el punto c la
dirección de rotación en un ángulo
positivo es en contra de las manecillas
del reloj entonces vamos a rotar en esta
dirección
ajá ahora el punto ps mapea en aquí
vamos a poner las coordenadas del nuevo
punto p después de realizar la rotación
de 180 grados
esta es la imagen de p llamémosla t
prima entonces bueno después vamos a dar
a decir si la distancia de prima se es
aquí vamos a decir si es menor que igual
a o mayor
que la distancia de pc entonces bueno
voy a rotar aquí 180 grados
esto sería 90 grados ahora 180 grados
sería esto dónde quedó el punto p ok
vamos a seguirlo otra vez entonces aquí
está la original ajá este es el original
y no puedo ahí está ok perfecto entonces
vamos a seguirlo ahí va el punto p 180
grados sería éste el nuevo punto p sería
p prima cierto de prima así que voy a
poner las nuevas coordenadas del punto p
sería 5,15 coma menos 1 i
la distancia de p prima hace
es menor que igual o mayor como hicimos
una rotación no expandimos la imagen ni
nada de eso simplemente hicimos una una
rotación
las distancias se mantienen se quedan
igual entonces es igual a y ahora vamos
a comprobar la respuesta tenemos la
respuesta correcta perfecto